does it work
hello everybody I'm Stefan and let me
introduce myself I don't have slides I
decided to say envious code only so
let's see how this goes
I am from Berlin Germany and I'm do
front-end JavaScript stuff for quite a
little bit now and I work for a company
that is so it's not great I work for a
company that is called Twilio so if you
wonder how to do phone calls SMS
whatsapp video emails and all these kind
of things we are scripting and
programming you can check that out and
the thing that I want to show you
actually is is this for two years now I
do something that is called today I
learned if you're following Twitter you
will see a lot of people that just share
what they learn and they are not scared
about being recognized as being not a
senior developer or not an experienced
developer so what I want to show you is
basically this this is my private
website I'm doing this now for two years
right and every time when I sit in front
of my computer and I'm like huh I didn't
know that then I put it on my website so
and sometimes it's notes like this which
is literally takes me two minutes but I
put it on my website and share it and
tweet it and sometimes people are like
huh Stefan thanks for sharing that's
super cool so what I want to do in the
next eight minutes is I want to share
it's just ten random things that are
learned in JavaScript and I put on my
website and I will face it in interviews
code so what I want to do is so you see
a main function and then I'm using
console.log and you see the NDC Oslo
there is the result of function okay so
let's talk about Jason stringify so json
stringify has a function that utilizes
your object to a string this first of
all has more operators so you can define
it replace a function and a indentation
if you want to but what I actually
learned two weeks ago is that if you
have an object that has a function -
Jason you can totally mess that up so
Jason's 25 will not string me for your
object anymore but will return and
serialize what you have in there this is
useful when you want to get rid of
sensitive information or things like
this so let's go on a string comparison
is another thing right when you compare
these two strings well you could now do
something like to lowercase here to
figure out if it's the same sequence of
characters but
how do you do this buddy here right that
is a tricky one you could now go into
all the code points and maybe figure
these things out but what turns out is
that when you're dealing in JavaScript
what you can do is there's a function
that is called local compare and that
accepts a few parameters but what you
can do is hear that this little function
is a very kind helper if you want to
compare super fancy characters like this
like this I mean we're in Norway we also
have this cross oh right so you can use
this and we'll tell you if the base of
the character sequence is the same I
think that can be very handy this is a
very slow function though so we have to
be careful with this one so let's take
talking up another one so for example
I'm German and we have these characters
and you can represent this character in
two ways you can also do it with two
code points so as you see this is
represented in the same thing but it is
actually not the same thing so when you
go to when you log out the lengths of
these word lengths and like word length
you will see that well one has one code
point or what you can do in JavaScript
is there's a function that is called
normalize which fixes this behavior
which is actually really cool because
this way you can guarantee that your
validation passes so and now we're
talking about arrays already let's have
a look at a reader from so area from
accepts any argument and tries to verify
it right so what you see there is the
string that is split into areas what we
can do now is we can write a map
function and we can map all the
characters and maybe use my fame with my
favorite emoji which is this one which
is this one so that's pretty cool but
three weeks ago or something I learned
that area from actually has a second
argument so you can do this in 1/1 which
is pretty sweet and you can save some
lines for this so and let's talk about
our favorite example is not a number
right so we've got this global function
javascript is not a number which
basically does not tell you if something
is this data type is not a number but
only if something would be parsed to
another number so what you see here is
that it's not a number returns true for
all these three and but knit this one so
and if I want to figure out if actually
not a number is something what we did
four years is my is now the number is
wrote our own function to figure out if
something is actually the datatype not a
number so this would now return a not
equals a because not a number is not
equal to itself we're speaking
JavaScript so that is cool so you can't
do this now and now you could figure out
if it's really it not a number but it
turns out just because we're dealing
JavaScript there's another not is enum
so it's this one and this is actually
doing what we're supposed to do right so
when you're dealing with is none be
aware that the global is none is not
equal number is none good luck with this
one so let's talk about index off so
when you want to figure out if something
is in an array where we did four years
is we use index off and then if it's a
minus one right then we know that in
value is not in the array so what we can
now do is we can change this to one two
three for example or to something like
this right but how can we now figure out
if not a number is in there right that's
actually a tricky one because not a
number is not equal to itself so the
comparison doesn't work so for right now
we have earlier include some JavaScript
which actually makes that possible which
is super cool so index off is not the
same comparison as array dot includes so
maybe this will hit you at some point
this is a very tricky one to spot so
let's talk about function parameters so
what we have here is a function inside
of another function and did you know
that you can call length on functions so
what you see now is that this shows the
arguments that are available on the
function which is pretty sweet right
this can be like helpful when you may be
writing library but what if we do
something like this which is a rest
operator in JavaScript well this is
completely messing it up right it's not
telling you anything anymore
something's wrong it's not telling you
anything anymore which might be a key
right because Arc's takes all the rest
arguments in this whole thing but this
got me thinking again what about default
parameters nope not going into this so
when you use function of length be
careful because there's a lot of tricky
thing in there and I'm also secretly in
love with regular expressions on what my
order completion doesn't work anymore
here we go so what you see is a regular
expression for three characters actually
is an a it's a period which is every
character right and the C so it can now
go in here I can change things and we'll
stay true which is really nice but
actually the period in JavaScript
regular expression is not matching every
character let's take a line break in
there damn it
so what we can do is we can use the dot
all flag which finally fixes this
behavior so that all flag fixes this
cool so you have to be aware of when you
do regular expression on big JavaScript
strings so speaking about regular
expressions let's go on here and this
actually surprised me because not many
people are using this so I have a
regular expression where the group that
checks for Jana John then anything in
between right and another string with
which is which is Smith or Smith this
means now when I have something here in
the middle something like whatever and I
use string dot match I have the matching
string here I have the first group the
group I am NOT interested in and the
second group right so what I did for
years in JavaScript with arrays is then
I pick index one and a pig index free
and index two is just hanging there for
nothing it turns out there are also non
capturing groups which helped me to get
rid of this I don't know what people are
not using this but this can be very very
handy and then finally let's talk about
finally which is always a weird thing to
me that this behaves like this so we
have your function with a try-catch
statement and this returns something
what happens we're in a now bringeth in
a finally now we all right async and
wait
so we write more dry catches and let's
return something here I'm the boss so
this now overrides the first return
statement which surprised me initially
what is going on here so but let's play
around a little bit let's throw an error
here it's still finally and what if we
throw an error here still finally it
turns out when you're using finally
finally is always right which is a
bummer so over the years of two years I
made it 283 documented learnings like
this covering JavaScript CSS HTML
accessibility whatever you whatever I
come across and what I really want to
tell you is that this is a lot of fun
and what I would like you to do is just
do the same because it doesn't take much
time especially when your developer you
feel like you're stuck and you're not
progressing and everything is new and
all the people knows so much stuff we're
gonna have this lists on your website or
even on your computer that's super cool
and sometimes I'm just tweeting this out
and a few peoples are like Stefan this
is so amazing you make my day and this
makes my day right so and ah caps lock
come on and this is what I had to say
I'm chef M and we're sponsoring
downstairs so if you want to say hi
[Applause]